IFRS is clearly more than an exercise in accounting.
And I think that's one of the biggest fallacies that companies have...
...as they are approaching the adoption of IFRS as nothing more than an accounting exercise.
When in reality, it impacts a number of different aspects of a company's business.
For example, not only is the accounting relevant,...
...but probably even more critical than the accounting aspect is the information technology,...
...and the impact that it may have on your IT systems.
IFRS is, first and foremost of course, an accounting policy exercise,...
...which is like any other time that you're changing the way that you do business.
It has the potential of having fundamental impact to your people, to your processes,...
...frankly down to the underlying transactional systems that derive your financial statements.
When you look at the accounting issues that impact technology companies,...
...there's probably no issue that is more dear to every technology company's heart than revenue recognition.
And clearly, as you look at the major accounting principles,...
...that's going to be number one on every company's list.
One of the areas that has the potential for creating a lot of change from a technology company perspective...
...is in the area of research and development.
You know, under US GAAP policies, most of our clients expense both research and development costs.
Under IFRS, there's the opportunity or in fact, the requirement to capitalize research cost.
Seems simple on its face.
The reality of it is, though it has implications to not only the accounting policy first,...
...but the processes, the people, the systems.
This is an area where software companies have been required for 20 - plus years to capitalize their development cost.
Not the research, but just the development.
This is an area now that under IFRS, all technology companies will be required to look at.
But not only are there potentially people impacts in terms of software engineers now having to account for their time,...
...you have to have systems that are gonna be able to track that time,...
...and then a way to be able to get that data all the way to the general ledger,...
...to be able to get those numbers out of the system.
So, one of the things that we suggest companies look for and try to do or perform early on...
...is some type of what we would call a gap analysis.
Looking at the differences between your current accounting,...
...whether that's US GAAP or whatever standard you're on and IFRS,...
...and identify those major areas that will require significant change between what you're doing now,...
...and what you'll need to do when you adopt to IFRS.